it's the beach a couple of nerds at the
beach we're actually quite far away from
the ocean cuz they they're sharks in
manners very nervous about orcas he
keeps being like it's an orca gonna eat
me and I'm like I'm out if you're eight
inches in the wall good morning John
good morning Hank it's Friday it is
Friday
uh-huh how your hot dog likes fertile
day star shining its radiation down upon
us I can feel it giving me cancer right
is the visible sign of the invisible
light that's TS Eliot it's lovely but it
doesn't mean anything to me when I ask
Henry what light is he always says in
his cute little four year old voice it's
the visible sign of the invisible light
I find question Friday the day that we
answer real questions from real
nerdfighters kick our laptop down to the
beach cuz that's how we roll why on the
screen I'm a little worried the year I'm
worried I'd lens Melissa wants to know
what is the art assignment going to
premiere first episode of the r7 comes
out late February subscribe link in the
dooblydoo he also wants to know who the
eff is Hank Oh
prepared for this why I'm never ready
make is the second largest ocean on
earth let me know which one that is this
one oh no I think this is the Gulf but
whatever you two are fighting and your
only weapons were the objects to your
left
how would you use them and who would win
have a chair and that are you I could
just beat you with you oh yeah I just
have to say good I would sand Hanks
computer because there's nothing that
would upset him more he would paint it
Danny wants to know how come Dave Green
is never in the video Thursday the third
unsuccessful brother dave has been made
up by tumblr how did this happen I
didn't even know about it suddenly I
have an imaginary brother Amy wants to
know why is love so hard I was really
not even close I want to beat you
looking at is funny by the way
the people on the beach they think that
we're crazy the people on the beach they
think that were crazy should always be a
little bit of work because matter yeah
that's true anyway there's all different
kinds of love there's all different
kinds of farts this is a really good
YouTube video we should we should do
this did you do this more often comments
tell me all the different kinds of farts
so in comments tell us about Dave green
just I need that no I need that John we
need the
for the rest of the video so no so go
get some glue beautiful Wendy wants to
know which of you has the worst glasses
prescription Oh No let's take a
switcheroo here definitely me yeah
definitely you Wow
wait till you're away I'm on acid right
well yours is very sharp but none of the
things are you're lining up your left
eye is almost identical to my left eye
your right eyes yeah the right are weird
who looks better do I look like a
naughty professor who looks better than
the others glasses set is that a thing
naughty professor I don't think so I
think you made that up
it's uh what is it then it's nutty a
nutty professor that's what you're asked
if you could tell me anything about The
Fault in Our Stars trail ah mm-hmm it
will come out soon in the next few weeks
and um yes I have seen it I thought it
was truly excellent I hope other people
like it - I'm very nervous for everyone
to see it but hopefully soon John thanks
for being on a question video with me no
no thing I'd taken me here to Florida
where I probably got a sunburn just in
the last 20 minutes
I have sunscreen on I didn't do that
best wishes you need to wrap up this
video hey I need to go because I may
actually not survive this I'll see you
on Tuesday
this is a very small motion you put me
in